many of the people that I know who have  tremendous amounts of money huge fears  around being poor a lot of people who  don't have money see people who have  money as thinking differently they are  more uncomfortable being poor than you  are being really it might be why some of  them are stingy too without money or two  nights ago to dinner with a guy who just  got valued at a billion and it's all  cash flow and he's like I'm not going to  that gym he's like for equal and I said  I'm gonna pay 200 a month for a gym  membership it's a different perspective  he got to that point because he squeezed  everything out of his business which  made the business so valuable and then  he was able to sell it the billion  dollar guy was saying he's like you know  they don't tell you about when you sell  your business mommy you sell your  business he's like you have no cash flow